i was particularly pleased that the
first story you ever told on the show
about 20 years ago is in the book it's
the one where uh you'd park on a double
yellow line for a few moments do you
know this oh yes yes well that that had
its repercussions of course because well
i i mean i parked on a double yellow
line in shaftesbury avenue
it was um the day of the state opening
of parliament
and i rushed up to give a take a tape
and audio tape because you know i do
audio tapes to my agent and i came
downstairs there was a policeman
pasting um a parking
ticket on my windscreen
and i was just furious because i'd only
been there for a minute and so you know
i tore it off the windscreen and i said
you've got a dick that small
because i thought the best thing is to
insult him as quickly as possible
of course and he took umbrage
didn't like it and he arrested me
for a breach of the piece
and uh parking on a double yellow line
and um then he called for help from
other policemen and there were lots
about because it was the state opening
of parliament and you know they're
mingling around and so um i was taken in
a in a police car to beau street police
station
and um there i was arraigned and um
they said uh
empty your handbag and i had
a few things in my handbag and one of
them was a packet of peppermints but
they're wrapped in silver paper you see
and that the detective
in charge thought that it was drugs
and he said um
you know what have we got here then
that's interesting and i said it's just
a packet of peppermint's officer
and he said no i think we better check
you out matron and he got the um the
matron to come and uh put me in a room
privately
and i knew
i knew because i was sharp
that she was going to give me an
internal examination i just knew that
nothing had been said but i knew it so
when she locked the door she went out
for a bit i took all my clothes off
immediately
when you would you know you know you're
going to be examined
and she came back in and she said
you've been here before
i said i have not been here before she
said yes you have how did you know to
take your clothes off
and i said well i know you're going to
examine me aren't you they called you
matron so i knew something was afoot
so
um
she said anyway bend down or lie on the
couch or something and
she
examined me my front body and my back
and of course they thought i wouldn't
like it
[Applause]
[Music]
you